if you could go anywhere in the whole
world where would you go I always wanted
to be part of something bigger yes
Milan is about a group of people who
find themselves in early Hollywood at a
time of extreme depravity and debauchery
and excess
[Applause]
it's the biggest thing I've ever tried
to do action
it was such an insane time it was just
wild like the Wild West
story follows multiple characters to
have an ambition to be a part of
something bigger than themselves we've
got to innovate we gotta inspire
Jack Conrad is the biggest film actor at
the top of his game and he's calling a
lot of the shots take two frames off the
tail in Fremont the head Manny is our
guide through the story these are eyes
and ears from an outsider's point of
view he's a dreamer someone that is
trying to find his way you can feel it
in something bigger than life
Nelly is an aspiring actress she's like
a tornado hello
and she's not gonna let anyone stand in
her way I got here on my terms not
theirs
it's a uniquely different cinematic
experience and it's going to be truly
amazing
it shows a side of Hollywood beyond what
you could have imagined
I mean so much trouble
people are going to be really shocked to
see how crazy it was is this gonna be
what it's gonna be
it's really funny at times look at
things yet
it's really sexy at times the film is so
big it's really an epic
it's just phenomenal
[Applause]
he looked Gray
laughs
[Music]